listening to
the interview you did with howard stern
and i know you said
that initially you might have misled the
studio into thinking you were doing
something a little more
silly and commercial so i got curious
how did the idea
look when you first pitched it compared
to the final product
um i would think that like uh maybe
projections were made that we did not
correct as far as what the tone
and style of the movie was going to be
um
you know i think when you uh are
filming a movie for a big studio
that you have starred in many big
comedies for in the past and that
movie's about
you playing two roles one of whom is a
old eastern european jew and the other
is great grandson
i think you know there was the there's
the version that you assume we're gonna
make and we did not
um dissuade them from assuming that was
what we were making
i appreciated the unique texture and
tone to this so i'm glad you went that
route
i know about the whole beard thing and i
know that you're a producer
on this movie so in a sense what you say
goes
but did anyone need any extra convincing
to actually
let you schedule the movie that way
where you have to hit so many locations
twice
it was i mean i mean yeah there was
there were a few conversations about how
much easier everything would be if i
wore a fake beard in just a few scenes
but then
i thought that would even worse honestly
like i thought after you know listening
to or seeing me with a you know real
beard for
ninety percent of the movie those ten
percent you know instances would really
stand out negatively so
um no it overall yeah i mean it
it was it was a difficult logistical
choice
but i think it makes the viewing
experience uh better in my opinion
how about just for you as an actor and
performer
does actually you know having the rea
not just having the real beard but being
able to shoot all of one character's
experience and then go back and do the
other help you
um it did i think yeah i think it was
helpful to stay in the mindset
um of one character for a while and then
switch to the other
and and also yeah i mean just
logistically performing with a fake
beard is a nightmare
that i did not want to do every day
can you tell us a little bit about the
whole beep system too
i was i was hearing a little bit about
that and wondering is that a technique
you guys came up with to nail this kind
of process or is that something that
just
existed that you knew you could use if
you needed
i honestly have no idea um i've never
done it before it's something we use
beeps when we do adr it's a similar
thing like beeps being used for timing
cues is is
is something that is done in the
entertainment industry you know but
um yeah i had never had to
do that but i've never done a movie with
uh
you know this type of visual effects
like this the end has a lot of visual
effects but it's all stuff that's added
in
post we're not like matching to anything
as soon as you're matching to things
that have been shot already it's uh a
whole other ball game and so
the beeps were a constant part of my
life for a very long time but
um luckily i have okay rhythm uh i hope
you don't i hear him in your sleep now i
think i'm getting the rad lip sign
so to close out here i have to ask
because you're talking to a gigantic
ninja turtles fan who is your favorite
ninja turtle and two
what is it about your movie that's going
to make it stand out from the other
ninja turtle feature films we've seen
before
michelangelo is definitely my favorite
ninja turtle um
you know as a lifelong fan of ninja
turtles
uh weirdly the teenage part of teenage
mutant ninja turtle is always the part
that stuck out to me the most
um and as someone who loves teenage
movies and who has
made a lot of teenage movies and who
literally got their
start in their entire profession by
writing a teenage movie
um the idea of kind of honing in on that
element was
really exciting to us um and and
and focus no i mean not disregarding the
rest but really using that as kind of a
jump jumping off point for for the film
i like the sound of that and uh huge
congratulations on this as well
absolutely awesome thank you thank you
appreciate it